today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling disney uh there
are many
reasons why you might think we could
cancel disney you could cancel them
for pretty much every movie they've
released for the past 25 years or so
because they've all been bad but
today we're canceling them for a
different reason for being racist and
oppressive the details of disney's
persecution of minorities are
difficult to stomach but we must not
avert our gaze we must not look away
this is real
this is happening face it the daily wire
has the report
actor john boyega who played the
character finn in the disney
star wars saga denounced the film's
producers for allegedly sidelining all
the minority characters
and giving all the white characters more
nuanced story lines speaking to british
gq
boyega said that his advice for disney
going forward would be to
not market a quote black character who
they eventually sideline
he said quote you get yourself involved
in projects and you're not necessarily
going to like everything
uh it's reported by the los angeles
times but quote
what i would say to disney is do not
bring out a black character market them
to be much more important than the
franchise than they are and then have
them
push to the sideline it's not good i'll
say it straight up
boyega charged that disney quote knew
what to do
with daisy ridley and adam driver's
character while not having a clue what
to do with oscar isaac
oscar isaac uh kelly tran or himself
he said quote like you guys knew what to
do with daisy ridley you knew what to do
with adam driver
uh you knew what to do with these other
people but when it came to kelly murray
tran
uh or when it came to john boyega you
knew f all so
what do you want me to say what what
what they want you to say is i enjoyed
being a part of it it was a great
experience nah nah
i'll take that deal when it's a great
experience they gave all the nuance to
adam driver all the nuance to daisy
ridley
let's be honest daisy knows this adam
knows this
everybody knows this i'm not exposing
anything
boyega opened up about the racism he
experienced from the star wars fan base
as well which was uh at its hottest when
the trailer for the force awakens was
first released
and uh he continued in his complaints
it makes you angry with a process like
that it makes you much more militant it
changes you
because you realize uh i got given this
opportunity but i'm in an industry that
wasn't even ready for me
nobody else in the cast had people
saying that they were going to boycott
the movie
uh because of uh because they were in it
okay there it is
uh sorry i you know stumbling a little
bit there i could barely finish reading
it through
the tears john boyega hollywood actor
worth millions has suffered in ways that
you simply cannot fathom
now you might listen to his complaints
and say first of all the reason the
black
actors in the star wars movie didn't
have nuanced roles
is that nobody in star wars had nuanced
roles because they were bad stupid
films hardly written and existed only as
elaborate toy commercials
you might also say that disney
prioritized wokeness over storyline in
star wars
and in everything else they produced
these days you might point out that i
mean they're literally reshooting their
old movies and recasting the white
characters as black
i mean you might say what more do you
want them to do
you might you might say also that john
boyega is just frankly not a very
interesting or good actor and he's lucky
to have been given
any role at all i mean the plumber who
came to fix my toilet last week could
have probably done a more compelling job
in that role than him
you might say so the fact that he's made
millions from a role that he brought
nothing to
should just cause him to be grateful the
way that i'm grateful that you all watch
this show despite the fact that i also
have no talent
you might also say finally that if
disney sidelined john boyega at all
it was mostly because they were
determined to turn star wars into a
girl power movie and that's why all of
the male protagonists were sidelined
even freaking luke skywalker was in the
move all three movies
he was in them for a total of about 22
seconds because they were more focused
on you know being gender woke than
racial woke and so
if john boyega has any complaint that
should be the complaint
you might say if you are a racist
if you're not a racist you realize that
john boyega
now joins the ranks of michelle obama
lebron james
oprah winfrey as celebrities who are
rich admired and oppressed
and if you are a white person living in
a two-bedroom rancher
taking your 12-year-old ford escort to
your 37 thousand dollar a year job at
the local walmart distribution center
you simply cannot understand the
oppression and a person
and persecution of celebrities who live
in homes as big as the warehouse you
work in
and who get paid more in a year than
you'll make in a lifetime you will never
know their struggle as much as you'd
like to because their struggles
certainly seem more glamorous and
profitable than your own
so disney is canceled for oppressing
the people that it pays millions of
dollars to
and you are cancelled for daring to
assume
that a person is not oppressed just
because they're rich
famous powerful and free how dare you
how dare all of you prayers up for john
boyega
in this difficult time
moment of silence
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated